jo Victor unsere Frage an dich
ist deine Community steigt täglich und
wir fragen uns achtest du da sehr drauf
und freust du dich auch oder
interessierst du dich da nicht so drauf
und machst deine Videos immer weiter und
weiter ja das würde uns mal
interessieren Grüße von S bis dann Ciao
hallo es ja eure Frage will ich
beantworten es freut mich auf jeden Fall
dass ich meine Abonnenten bekomme und
mittlerweile habe ich über 130.000 jedes
Mal wenn ich dann eine neue Zahl
erreiche ob das jetzt nun 120.000 125
oder 130 000 ist ich freue mich über
jeden Abonnenten und es ist ich
realisiere es gar nicht also ich habe
zwar Erfolg das ist klar aber ich
realisiere es gar nicht mehr so richtig
also ich werde zwar auf der Straße
erkannt aber immer wieder wenn ich
erkannt werde dann finde ich das einfach
komisch auch wenn ich schon öfter
erkannt werde aber ich freue mich auf
jeden Fall und ich freue mich auch dass
ihr meine Videos schaut